hey this is presh talwalkar reminding
you to my your decisions
all of the problems in this video are
based on india's jee main test which is
a precursor to the exam to get admission
into iit
students have about one and a half
minutes per question
see how many you can solve
problem one
the integral from two to four of the
square root of x all over the square
root of six minus x plus the square root
of x
problem 2
the integral from 0 to pi over 2 of the
square root of sine of x
all over the square root of sine of x
plus the square root of cosine of x
problem 3 the integral from the cube
root of log of 3 to the cube root of the
log of 4
the numerator is x squared multiplied by
the sine of x cubed and the denominator
is the sine of x cubed plus the sine of
the quantity log of 12 minus x cubed
these are all tricky problems
pause the video if you'd like to give
them a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve these
problems in seconds
[Music]
there's an incredible technique to solve
all of these problems quickly
the integral from a to b of f of x all
over f of a plus b minus x plus f of x
is equal to b minus a all over two
i learned about this on the youtube
channel they don't through jee
the proof is at the end of the video
and we're going to assume things like
the function f is well defined from the
interval a to b
but on the exam you're going to get
normal functions so you can go ahead and
apply this formula
so let's use this formula to solve the
problems
let's consider this first integral
let's write f of x is equal to the
square root of x
this is there in the numerator and it's
also there in the denominator
now square root of six minus x will
exactly be equal to f of a plus b minus
x
this integral therefore follows this
formula exactly
and we can then evaluate it as b minus a
over two
so this answer will be equal to four
minus two all over two
and the answer is one
incredible we solve this complicated
integral
very simply using this formula
let's consider this next integral
it again fits this formula but it's a
little bit trickier to see
let's write f of x is equal to the
square root of sine of x
we have that in the numerator and the
denominator
what about the square root of cosine of
x
well if you think about it this is
exactly equal to f of pi over 2 minus x
so we again
fit this template and we can evaluate
this integral as b minus a over two
so it'll be equal to pi over two minus
zero all over two and this simplifies to
be pi over four
incredible we solved another tricky
integral with this formula
now what about this final integral
we can't apply the formula right away
we'll do a substitution
let's write u is equal to x cubed
d u will be 3 x squared dx
we divide both sides by 3 to get d u
over 3 is equal to x squared dx
so we can substitute in for x squared dx
du over 3
we then factor this 1 3 out of the
integral
now let's do this substitution u is
equal to x cubed it'll simplify the
limits of integration and the arguments
of the functions
we're pretty much ready to apply the
formula but we just need one more
observation
if f of u is equal to sine of u then f
of a plus b minus u is equal to sine of
log of 3 plus log of 4 minus u
we can simplify this because log of 3
plus log of 4 is equal to log of 3 times
4 which is equal to log of 12.
the integral therefore exactly fits our
formula
we can evaluate the integral part using
b minus a over two
so the integral will be log of four
minus log of three all over two which
simplifies to be log of four over three
all over two and now we need to remember
to multiply this by one third
so the final answer will be one sixth
multiplied by the log of four thirds
and we've solved this incredibly
complicated integral
very easily
so now we want to do a quick proof of
why this formula is true
let's suppose that this integral is
equal to i
we'll do a substitution that u is equal
to a plus b minus x
d u will equal negative dx
so the integral becomes the following
again this will be equal to i because
we've done a change of variables
notice the limits of integration have
flipped
we'll flip them back and that'll cancel
out with this negative
now
notice that we have the variable u
this is a dummy variable and we'll
replace it with the variable x
so we have two different integrals that
are equal to i
let's add these up together
the result will be 2i
and on the left-hand side it'll be the
sum of these functions going from a to b
well the sum of these functions will
exactly cancel out this is equal to one
so we have the integral of one from a to
b
and that will be equal to b minus a
so i is equal to b minus a over two and
that's exactly what we wanted to prove
that this formula is equal to b minus a
over two
and we've proved it
remember this technique and you'll solve
many integrals in seconds
thanks for watching and for making mind
your decisions one of the best channels
on youtube
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support
[Music]